uh just
now we're moving into swat here we go
special police units as we speak are
taking up positions
okay i look i see that and i understand
that they are and all that
special police but why why are you
dressed like a mormon
asia carrera yeah maybe
why why are you dressed like a no not a
mormon why are you dressed amish
that's the outfit the reporter's wearing
seriously is she going to an amish wake
as we speak are taking up positions at
the suspected major drug lab
that's not a drug like that's just
lakeland that joke is for like the
people who live in florida you'll get
that
cyberpunk
it's a hooker are we supposed to shoot
the hooker
i guess you are supposed to shoot the
hooker
i'm sorry so the woman on the swat team
doesn't have to wear body armor or a
helmet
she could wear glasses she can wear the
glasses you could have to go to the eye
doctor and a beret
and that's the same thing what was a
costuming department on this whatever
[ __ ] the director had laying around his
house
don't shoot i'm also a hooker but you
know the good hooker not the
not the gun hooker i'm not i'm not i'm
not the shooting kind of hooker
that guy though that guy was a bad guy
you could tell cause of the overalls
how many people were in this [ __ ]
trailer this really is lakeland
[Music]
[Laughter]
how do you continue to [ __ ] why would
he be on fire
what happened that there would be a big
blowing up isn't being set on fire
yeah i'm with you man if zack you're
right i'm i'm actually
for if these are the police that are out
there they need to be defunded defund
these kind of police please
please defund these police
he's on [ __ ] fire and not like in the
good way on fire
really hot because when you're burning
too literal
death you're gonna do three stooges
sounds that that's that's how you know
it's real
you do three stooges sounds
[Music]
oh
[Music]
this is a game that doesn't even want to
take itself seriously or not
welcome to the team ma'am are you blind
because look i i get diversity but i
don't think we should be having blind
cops
am i wrong here blind cops probably
isn't the best
although i would watch that show blind
cops
you'll fit right in pick a mission
[Applause]
thank robert send help bank robbery
send help that's how you would call the
police
these guys look tough do you think you
can handle it i don't
care anymore ma'am to be honest with you
are you the head of the swat team
because no
he's okay
[Music]
look at that old computer
blind cops i like that chris blind cops
i don't see race
i smell it
[Music]
this place is like a jungle let's go
whoa racist
[ __ ] racism
[Music]
union
you have time to make a funny union joke
don't shoot me i'm union
intarnation are you doing
he's a banker you shoot him too shoot
him both
i would shoot the banker and go now
you're sir you're safe now
no more prep no predatory loans for you
just shoot the banker at the head and be
like sir
you're safe everything's gonna be all
right i took care of the threat
[Music]
about that new car loan
something about him
didn't tell him when they're filming
this outside and the real cops show up
and really shoot these people
so they have literal bags of money like
a cartoon
i'm ready i'm ready for the next mission
oh they're back in lakeland
[Music]
this maple says after you shoot him you
have to go
your account's closed
terrible 80's catchphrase
guess i just made a deposit
[Music]
oh
oh they killed danny trejo
good thing that mattress was there
shooter she's another prostitute just
i would do this mission and just shoot
the prostitutes also
why is she dressed like she's in the
village people
[Music]
hey i was taking a [ __ ] with my pants on
[Music]
[Applause]
so that old man was in the gang that old
man
nice work partner you murdered people
you extinguish the soul from their body
the light out of their life
and you're happy about this
welcome to the force pick a mission
now you're delta force that's the after
swat you become
delta force is that how it
are works in position okay this one's
already are these are criminals
two in four
targets we don't want any civilian
casualties
good honey let's rock
let's rock
oh in the final level you become dan
crenshaw yeah the problem with is you
only see half the screen
make sure to shoot the dog
the tires are also bulletproof
what was he repelling in from and why
what
what is the point of repelling in in
this it's not a secret mission
everyone could see you
oh [ __ ] now we're shooting somebody's
here we go now we got hey
now we're talking now we're shooting
some
let's do it let's take them out folks
let's take them out
they were trying to hijack that jet
[Music]
um what if you shoot one of the
passengers
[Music]
wait a second i'm fair i i sorry
but i gotta ask a question okay
did you notice it because i noticed it
[Music]
why is it
working with a cowboy i i'm
what what's hap why
working with a texas cowboy is this an
alliance i don't know what's happening
because i'm let me tell you something
i'm very concerned i am
very concerned
if there's a [ __ ]
working with a texas cowboy
this is not good folks we have a problem
crime patrol tried to tell us about this
and we ignored it
rob cavigan al akbar partner
isis the outpost division
bryant yeehaw that's wrong
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] man this is great
oh the team up you never knew what
happened
okay guys middle eastern again
lady do you want to get murdered
because that's how you get murdered save
us
save us save us
save us what are you doing lady
yes
and this what's this guy what's he a
part of
that guy that guy was a terrorist
boomer dad was a terrorist
jesus christ and starting to think
that everybody on this plane is a
terrorist
just kill everybody on the plane i'm
doing another speed run yeah i'm doing
speedrun
crime patrol doing so far so good
that guy to everybody so far
everybody on the plane has been a
terrorist
what why would you do that lady you've
been sitting there the entire time and
now's when you freak out
so she was there the whole time going
like you know i know there's a lot of
shooting going on and there's a lot of
straight bullets and stuff
but i got gotta make my cup of coffee
it is one of the video games we have to
shoot the screen you came in late it's
crime patrol was an old arcade game
oh that ought to be good for some
frequent flyer miles
i get it i get it i got it
did tarantino write this
good job partner welcome to the force
pick a mission
so i just i want to be clear so this is
how it works you go from b
cop undercover swat and then delta team
am i correct
is is that is that the the natural
progression in law enforcement
nuclear transport group advise of your
present location
standby base something here
rob you shot my partner i've known for
30 years he's got a wife and six kids
that should be good for some frequent
flyer miles
nuclear transport due to 10. we're under
attack bomb marker 25
it's in hell
are you the help
i like the music skipping because they
couldn't just skip the screen they had
to skip the music
let's
too
[Music]
you did a great job did you now that's
the two of us get this stuff delivered
here at the nation's largest nuclear
power plant the city nuclear
it's pronounced nuclear situation is
critical
delta force members are attempting to
stop a terrorist plot to hijack
plutonium
so is it a good idea for the news to be
already broadcasting that plutonium's
out on the loose and
they're trying to stop a plot from it
like is that how it works
let's rock
yes they're gonna hijack plutonium
they're going to hijack it
what did you get about that final limo
ride they're going to hijack plutonium
you don't ever hijack some
you know hijack walk in the store and
hijack some things
hijacking the plutonium what's the big
deal
[Music]
[Music]
you can tell it's radioactive because
there's construction paper with the
radioactive symbol on it that's what you
can tell
in less than 60 seconds we'll be in a
helicopter
and out of here
was that the bad guy why don't you just
shoot him or was that like not you was
that just like a scene that didn't
happen
i was able to see it
and i couldn't pick the accent up but
what nationality
was the terrorist was he from melmac
because that doesn't sound like a
[ __ ]
one i've heard on earth
[Music]
come on you can do it i'd rather not i
was just i was
i was literally a b cop 10 minutes ago
why am i in delta
i feel like you guys should have higher
standards
oh you can tell more radioactive
material it's plutonium
was it plutonium it's plutonium
quick the tacos escaping by helicopter
amanda let's return this fissionable
material back to its rightful owner
yeah the last stage is your mossad
oh [ __ ] the chopper exploded off screen
welcome to the force pick a mission
in an apparent attempt to assassinate
prince dudu and his entourage i'm sorry
what was the prince's name i missed it
in an apparent attempt to assassinate
prince dudu and his
[Laughter]
what was his name in an apparent attempt
to assassinate prince dudu
it's prince doodle
entourage terrorists have seized control
of the international airport
and as we speak the delta force members
are arriving on the scene
and are deploying
is this the final delta force mission i
think it is
remember no russian
[Music]
[Music]
so
that pilot that that that guy's got to
get to his flight he doesn't care if
people are shooting he's going to walk
right in front of the guns
this is crime patrol an old arcade game
from the 90s
[Music]
i'm sorry i got it back up here just a
bit
are there white people wearing
traditional african garb and is the guy
in the back also wearing blackface i
mean that's an actual black guy here on
the right but
the one behind him looks like he's
wearing blackface and the other two are
just white guys in african garb
[Music]
are we having fun yet no
this is going to haunt me forever i've
killed a thousand people sir
i'll never be able to sleep again um
this is going to affect my mind for a
very
very long time i'm sorry you considered
this fun
we murdered people we we killed
human beings we've been killing human
beings for 19
minutes and you found this fun
i guess this is a real police training
video
the advice gentlemen intel says that
well on be like kicking over that hill
good luck and good hunting
[Music]
why is it porn music now
[Music]
prop all these men we killed there were
babies once
little children like our own children
puts barrel of gun and mouth
[Music]
oh
hey good job in there
we did it guys we beat cyberpunk speed
run record
beat cyberpunk in 19 minutes and 12
seconds add that to my speed runs
another speed run completed by the king
of speed runs
take that other speed runners
crime patrol baby